super nice guy
um one of the biggest superstars in
music what's your guys's relationship
like
yeah my goddamn boy i fought one okay
what have you learned from him man
because
no cap it's funny because i i
sing of course but he definitely know
pitches and keys and that [ __ ] is so
dope to
have somebody in the studio with so much
knowledge and would lend you the ear
like i feel like [ __ ] take
ears for granted mm-hmm there's people
like him and south side and okay even mo
got a [ __ ] ear right
music you know what i mean so like when
you got young [ __ ] who who think they
know what they're doing listen to that
[ __ ] that's next to you with that ear
trust me that one thing he might change
may make your song be fi
turn it up you feel me and he's a crazy
producer
like bro we all like i think people who
who don't really like tap in with what
he does
mello made it right well but i'm saying
like people like we always like
associate him with like being this big
edm guy like this [ __ ] makes
slappers no
the records he's put out with roddy and
all these people are crazy if he was
black his tag should be
mellow maybe right [ __ ] like no cap
it's
it's that hard that he's just to say
mello made it right [ __ ] that [ __ ] is
hard like